une fois il est resté pendant plus de 16
heures face aux 10 par an qui se met à
part est l'ancien chef elle adorait il
était déjà mort ou tentatives de
manipulation son petit fils
ce type est tout sauf en train de
craquer pour y passer la nuit
je vais tenter autre chose c'est
n'importe quoi je te demande pas de
m'apprécier je te demandent d'obéir
parce que les dépôts mais je me ferme et
et en même temps vous n'imaginez tu es
fait on en faire là c'est la procédure
j'essaie de faire ce job en restant
derrière ton miroir ça marche pas comme
ça
quelques vous qui puissiez nous aider
tout ce qu'on veut c'est la vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]